taliban enter afghan capital as use
diplomats evacuate the chop reuters
story taliban insurgents entered
afghanistan capital kabul on sunday as
the united states evacuated diplomats
from the embassy by helicopter more
american troops were being sent to help
in the evacuations after the taliban's
lightning
advances brought the islamist group to
kabul in a matter of days just last week
the u.s intelligence estimate said kabul
could hold out for at least three months
after u.s led forces withdrew the bulk
of their remaining troops in the last
month the taliban campaign accelerated
as the afghan military defenses appeared
to collapse president joe biden on
saturday authorized the deployment of
five thousand u.s troops to help the
acuity citizens and ensure an orderly
and safe drawdown of the military
personnel us defense officials said that
included a thousand
newly approved troops from the 82nd
airborne division kai can you pull up
that video
i want to show the video with the plane
it's pretty i mean at this point of the
game people have seen this this thing's
probably gone a billion views and not
just this video here i mean there's make
it uh can you make it bigger
so this is a c17
i think it's called the ghost master
boeing
are hanging on
those people shouldn't be on the runway
by the way because they want to leave
they don't want to stay they're so
scared now give the other video
of the plane taking off kai
i don't know if uh listen this next part
either watch it but or don't watch it
but watch it at your own discretion
because
uh uh do you have it or you don't have a
guy
oh it's coming up okay
right there that's the one okay check
this out
that's just the picture yeah it's
see if you can find a video kai do you
have you seen a video for people that
don't know what it is man it's the the
people who are literally hanging on to
the wings and then they fall off in
mid-air
obviously it's not here can you go find
a video yeah
and and again it needs to be said
there are not people clinging on to
their fingernails into the wings of
airplanes to escape capitalist america
there are not people floating on on
rafts made of trash to escape capitalist
america will you don't
lower the audio a little bit
there's people on by the way
the guy's laughing that's not even the
one i'm looking at i'm looking for the
one where the plane takes off and you
see two bodies
yeah you know that's the one that's the
one watch this seven point six million
views look at that
oh that's a bite
that's another body that's two bodies
posit that's that's a disturbing scene
right
um
so again i got a bunch of notes here but
i'll go to you guys what do you what are
your thoughts when you see what's going
on over there
decision all of it yeah i've actually
taken some time to really do some
research here and really just kind of
formulate my thoughts um
so i i can kind of express
um
this very clearly um
so look let's just break this down into
what was then what is occurring now and
what the future will hold right so
um
what was then
so we
first and foremost before we even get
into any of the politics or what's going
on just
respect and appreciation for the
american troops that have been over
there for the last 20 years giving their
life for this cause i think you as a
former army
veteran and we have marines here let's
just start with with that first and
foremost uh as well as the afghani
people that you know there's translators
and communicators and everyone that's
been involved what 6 000 americans have
have given their lives and over 100 000
afghanis 20 years 2 trillion dollars
that's what's been when we went there
what were our goals initially we had a
few different goals specifically take
down al qaeda not the taliban al-qaeda
number two find osama bin laden i know
you interviewed his niece um
that took 10 years to do we went in
there in 2001 after 9 11.
and then when did obama find him in 2011
i want to say took 10 years of doing
that in my opinion we should have got
the hell out of there after our mission
was accomplished with osama bin laden um
for the past
i don't know five years whether it was
trump now biden
trump ran on no more endless wars get
the hell out of afghanistan did he not
no more endless wars what the hell are
we doing here so this is not a political
peaceful four years when he was
president there was not a lot of touche
he what back uh in
2020 he negotiated with the taliban the
afghani government wasn't even in the
room when he was negotiating with the
taliban that should have been a telltale
sign the afghan government no longer
controls this country trump negotiated
with the taliban so the writing's been
on the wall this was in may of 2020.
they said september 11th of 2021 the
20-year anniversary of 9 11 we're all
getting out of there so obiden just
basically
followed through what trump was doing so
that that was then the american people
definitely do not have an appetite for
this war anymore like for the most part
the overall sentiment is let's get out
of there now talk about today it's a
freaking [ __ ] show nobody wants
this type of exit strategy leaving
afghanistan nobody wants that um
what's for sure and we've seen this in
vietnam i can talk about we can go back
in the day judah and the maccabees when
jewish people were fighting the whoever
was attacking israel there's a big
difference in willpower so when you have
the taliban they're not going anywhere
they're not stopping
they're not ceasing we've been going
after them for 20 years it's like
whack-a-mole you're not stopping these
people and then the other side you have
the afghan forces who are basically
mercenaries getting paid the money's
dried up they stopped fighting have they
even fought they haven't have the will
power or the appetite to fight anymore
clearly not
um
president ghani ashwagani he's left the
country he's nowhere to be found they
they're gone so the taliban how that
we've talked i'm sure we're gonna touch
on how they've been making money drugs
and opium and basically
taxing people they've controlled half
the country for a while now um i do
sympathize with the women like
what you talked about the the girl
what's the young girl's name who won the
nobel peace prize uh malala she's come
out there and she's very definitely
vocalized and emphasized the need for
humanitarian
and and women
and bringing maybe immigrants back to
united states but biden basically came
out in his speech yesterday and he says
the buck stops with me whether you agree
with him or not agree with him i at
least respect the fact that he's owning
up to this he's taking ownership he's
not saying anyone else yeah he said we
did not think it was going to escalate
this fast just quickly it took 90 days
they expected 90 days it happened in 10
days which was faster than we took over
the country in 2001. let me put a a a
bow on this whole thing and that's
what's going on now let's talk about the
future and you brought up china
this is a regional issue okay united
states has been dabbling in this war
it's our longest war in american history
for 20 years now what have we
accomplished right like
we're not building democracies we're not
doing anything
uh we're not nation building this point
where this is a counter-terrorism
mission right
so moving forward
um what will our future look like
there's one country there's two
countries at the center of all this and
there will be from backlash from there
the countries at the center of this are
obviously pakistan who's been supporting
taliban not so secretly for 20 years
and in my and then who's supporting
pakistan china china is right behind
pakistan basically saying we got your
back
so the country that i think needs to
step up in all this in the absence of
the united states is india they border
china i'm sorry they border china they
border pakistan they're right on the
border afghanistan
and
if they don't want this [ __ ] show to
come into their country and have i mean
the border of pakistan and india has
already been called the what most
dangerous border in the world yeah so
in my opinion let's gonna see what
happens there's disputed territories as
well of course
um but basically in that region
obviously you have iran you have russia
and it's just
let's just see what happens there and
last but not least let's see what
happens here in the united states
because there's going to be political
fallout from this does this help biden
does this hurt biden in the midterms
short term let's let's focus on short
term this is not a good look long term
he's going to want he's going to be of
the one to say i got us out of
afghanistan obviously he's thinking
about that when the midterms come around
or if he runs for re-election so
um at the end of the day does this
situation make america look strong or
weak in my opinion weak
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]